you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news on today's programme
the government launches the uk's first
hydrogen strategy to transform the way
we power our lives but how green is it
the us declares the first ever water
shortage at the country's largest
reservoir as drought pushes water levels
to a record low
and the environmentalists cleaning up
lakes in india
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show and we start today at
our data dashboard and you can see here
on the top line where electricity in
great britain is currently coming from
and you can see there that 33 is coming
from fossil fuels 49 from renewables and
18 from nuclear
well hydrogen isn't on there because
currently only around one percent of
electricity is produced by it but that
could soon change the government's new
hydrogen strategy has been published
today suggesting that hydrogen could
make up one third of our energy mix by
2050. their proposal aims to burn
hydrogen as an alternative to oil gas
and coal to encourage the use of low
carbon fuel and cut greenhouse gas
emissions but campaigners say the new
plans to make hydrogen from fossil fuels
is not completely green well our science
correspondent thomas moore is here to
explain thomas
hydrogen is the invisible fuel of the
future but how it's made really matters
to the planet and the production method
has a color code gray hydrogen makes up
the majority of current production it's
made from natural gas or other fossil
fuels using a process called steam
methane reforming and it generates
carbon dioxide and methane emissions
blue hydrogen is made in the same way
but technology is used to capture most
but not all of the carbon dioxide
emissions for storage underground or
under the sea in theory this should mean
it is less polluting than grey hydrogen
but a recent study has found that the
production of blue hydrogen is far from
green due to the release of some methane
green hydrogen is zero carbon it's made
by using wind or solar to split water
into hydrogen and oxygen gases but it's
currently an inefficient process and
there's nowhere near enough spare
renewable capacity at the moment to make
the huge amounts of hydrogen we will
need in its new hydrogen strategy the
government wants to incentivize low
carbon production and to me the
definition is considering a target of 54
to 72 grams of carbon dioxide for every
kilowatt of energy roughly a third of
the emissions from burning natural gas
now many environmentalists would argue
it's a pretty soft target and it's
better to find a way of making hydrogen
with zero emissions to sustainably fuel
heavy industry buses lorries as well as
heating homes and thomas what are the
cost implications for consumers if we
were to move towards hydrogen so
the consultation released today says
that the the costs could be loaded onto
consumers through energy bills just as
they were in the early days of wind
energy when it's very expensive but as
it was scaled up the efficiencies came
and the cost of wind energy is now about
the same as any other fossil fuel
so that's the hope with hydrogen that by
putting the load on to consumers at the
beginning it would slowly come down
ultimately hydrogen would be an
extremely cheap way of fueling the
future so a cost for the consumers now
but probably not in the long term thomas
thank you
well don't forget you can see a more
detailed breakdown of the real
power mix in great britain on our
website head over to skynews.com
climate
in today's other climate news several
people have needed to be rescued from
flood waters in germany after sudden and
heavy rain the flooding caused a wooden
bridge in the valley of hell in bavaria
to be swept away severe weather
conditions also led to a state of
emergency in northern germany where a
storm destroyed more than 50 homes
and in france thousands of people have
been evacuated to escape wildfires
firefighters are tackling fires in the
french riviera that are threatening
homes and tourist spots it follows
fierce forest fires that have swept
across northern africa and europe in
recent weeks
and a chalk stream that feeds into the
norfolk broads will be the focus of a
1.6 million pound conservation project
the national trust who are leading the
project said there are just 200 chalk
streams left in the world it's hoped the
project that will create corridors for
wildlife will help britain's fastest
declining mammal the waterfall
now to the u.s where officials have
declared the first ever water shortage
at lake mead the country's largest
reservoir a prolonged drought across the
west has led to record low water levels
there so let's take a look at what's
happening then today now this is the u.s
drought monitor and you can see here
that large areas in the west are bright
red and dark red now these are the
places experiencing extreme and
exceptional drought
lake mead is in one of those red areas
running through arizona and nevada water
levels are at the lowest point since the
1930s when the reservoir was first
filled so what's going on
[Music]
[Music]
there's no doubt that climate change is
real we're experiencing it every day in
the colorado river basin and in other
basins in the west
[Music]
every community
every sector every industry that uses
colorado river water must do more to
conserve and protect this critical water
resource
well joining me now is jennifer pitt
colorado river program director for the
environmental organization the national
audubon society
welcome to you so lake mead's water
levels have been declared critically low
for the first time
so how concerning is that what impact
will that have am i right in thinking
that agriculture and drinking water are
perhaps amongst the most pressing
concerns
uh
this is a serious concern
but it's not unexpected
uh we've been watching the lake levels
decline for
most of the last 20 years i think the
biggest concern is not what we do about
shortages to
water users as you said to farmers and
perhaps some others in the short term
but
we have no reason to think that these
drought conditions are going to ease up
in the long term
we hope that they do but the warming uh
means that we could be facing
uh
these kind of shortages year after year
and that's the biggest concern
well yes and what impact do the
shortages have
uh well
this year or the coming year what we
expect is for the shortages to
largely be born by farmers in central
arizona and in mexico
and so there will be some reduction in
agricultural productivity in those
regions
and can anything be done about it
well in arizona they are working on a
mitigation plan that includes
uh
releasing water from local reservoirs
some
market transfers where actually people
who use water who are willing to
forgo their uses are selling it to allow
the farmers to have access to some of it
and
they are also going to allow those
farmers to return to pumping fossil
groundwater which of course will work in
the short term but is not a sustainable
solution
and what about the impact on wildlife in
the area
well uh we don't yet know we haven't
seen uh reductions of these kinds in the
water delivery so we haven't seen the
river flowing in the way it will be next
year but we do have concern for habitat
areas along the banks of the colorado
river that depend on the water flowing
by
to remain healthy and so we will be
keeping a close eye on it and as i said
these are
conditions that we expect to persist and
so as we
get a better understanding of
the impact on habitat areas it may be
necessary
to
make some investments to
improve the habitat areas such that they
can remain healthy at lower water levels
jennifer pitt thanks very much indeed
thank you
and the drought in california is
threatening the state's 6 billion almond
industry which produces about 80 percent
of the world's almonds more growers are
expected to abandon their orchards as
water becomes scarce and expensive
now many of india's waterways are
polluted filled with plastic waste and
raw sewage one man working to change
that is aaron krishnamurthy in 2010 he
quit his job at google to set up the
environmentalist foundation of india
since then the organization has restored
more than 150 freshwater lakes and ponds
across the country
lake is a magical world in itself to
abuse and exploit a lake happens only
when we don't understand its
significance
we don't understand that every lake or a
pond is a habitat in itself
which houses frogs snakes crabs turtles
birds so many different life forms
human beings directly depend on
underground water source so a lake or a
pond is necessary to replenish these
groundwater resources
[Music]
lakes and ponds also play a big role in
localized temperature regulation lakes
and ponds need to be cleaned so that it
doesn't cause any waterboard diseases to
the neighboring individuals
[Music]
we think we're superior because we can
walk straight and talk around and we
fail to understand that we're just one
of the several species in this planet
it's not about protecting the planet
anymore it's about our life our
livelihoods and from the urban ridge to
the urban poor the divine on who gets
affected by climate change
one thing which i realized is
everybody wants to be good everybody
wants to participate in planet
conservation efforts they just don't
know where to begin efi or other
organizations are platforms through
which people are realizing and living
their planet life
[Music]
and finally over half a million seeds
have been collected from healthy
seagrass meadows to be planted the ocean
conservation trust who are leading the
project plan to plant a total of four
hectares in the solent maritime special
area of conservation seagrass is vital
for marine life and can absorb large
amounts of carbon
well that's everything from us for today
coming up tomorrow meet six-year-old
climate activist alicia guadia who's
riding her scooter to save rainforests
thanks for watching see you then
[Music]